what would diana make of her boys and
their relationship now and how would she
try to mend it well the one thing that
she would be
really infuriated about would be the
fact that they've had this split and
because she always said to me on not
just once but on several occasions
harry is
william's backup in the nicest possible
way he's his wingman he's the one who
helps william in this difficult
job that he will have in the future
because it's a lonely job and she always
felt that harry should be there as
his backup and i think everybody wants
them to
come back together again because
together they're so much stronger
can they come back together given all
the factors now well
they've they've gone through this week
these last few days out of respect and
love for the queen and they behaved
impeccably
will they go back together it's down to
those two i mean you know megan and
harry are happy and have a life as
prince charles said in his opening first
statement
in in california they're the king and
queen of california their daughter is
now
an american princess the first american
princess princess lilliburg
they go to local schools i mean i don't
see them rushing back to britain apart
from occasional visits to see their
charities you know as they brought the
coffin in and the bagpipes were playing
it felt like you probably could hear
them across the city that it was so
quiet i've never
seen a city fall silent like it did for
this event
it was
it was special and it was different have
you ever seen london silent like this
well i i i saw it when when diana died
25 years ago and it was her funeral but
then there was a still shot there was
the whaley and keening of people going
with flowers and that that was a
an extraordinary event as well this was
different
it was more respectful there was no
anger there there was no
feeling of retribution that tinged
diana's funeral
there was
there was quite contemplation
and and there was love
for this lady who
we all say thank you to for her service
you